and they will take their swings off the
veteran right-hander matt harvey making
his 18th appearance of the year
for the month of april was solid june
and july have not been the same first
two men have reached for the blue jays
tonight vladimir guerrero jr who
that pitch into left field a great jump
by mckenna
and he comes up with a baseball
double play simeon had no idea and he's
going to be out ryan mckenna with
another spectacular play in left field
simeon thought the ball dropped
he's still not sure it was caught and
the orioles get two outs mckenna comes
out of nowhere watch this effort a line
drive a ball hit hard lays out and
catches it just or did he catch it wait
a minute no way
so
i think all of the runners are going to
be given a base and now
mark carlson has just pointed home
for simeon so marcus simeon is going to
be granted
home plate so the way this works is
umpire discretion as to where the base
runners would have advanced
assuming a no catch
ruling i think rightfully so is that
simeon would have scored because he got
to third base when we saw the out call
2-1 pitch springer pops it up right side
of the infield infield fly rule is
called valencia backs up and makes the
catch
and the 0-1 a ground ball hit to third
to second one and on to first not in
time not a good throw
from laba the third baseman that costs
the orioles and it gets the blue jays a
run as beshette crosses the play two to
nothing blue jays and here's kevin bizio
1-0
and bishop drives the ball left center
field and it's going to get down and
skip up over the fence
but good opposite field power for kevin
it is three to nothing blue jays
yeah 17th start this season is 10th on
the road he still has a very good era at
365. he's just been off his last couple
of starts
he gets mullins to chase down and away
and ryu strikes out the first batter
that he faces tonight one ball and two
strikes ryu to the plate
and it's hit on a line out to right that
is a base hit
sliding is hernandez knocks it down
loses his glove hazing for two throat
comes in it's offline and it's a double
for austin hayes
three two
change up and he got him to chase down
and away and he strikes him out two down
swing and a miss at a curve ball and ryu
strikes him out
ground ball to third charged by biggio
low throw dug out by guerrero at first
austin wins will give it a try with men
at the corners and the blue jays up
three nothing
curve ball and he got him good pitch by
ryu his fourth strike out of the night
the orioles leave a couple of men on and
the blue jays still lead three to
nothing
and that is a jam shot but leica makes
the catch over to first it's a double
play
matt fired up to get some good defense
behind him
and he'll hope for some more here zuria
scoops a hernandez ground ball mount
castle kept the foot on the bag and matt
faces the minimum in the third
[Applause]
the 3-1 is golf to left field but not
that deep ludus goriel's right there one
down
fastball grounded to short right at
beshette
and the throwing plenty of time
2-2
swing and a miss and ryu strikes out
mound castle to win the inning
one-two for grichik
and down he goes
[Applause]
a good swing by bishop and he lines it
into right field and he is on his way to
second and in there ahead of the throw
we've got a runner with second one out
we'll go to scoriel
another good swing by gorielle and he
lines it into center for a base head
bisho around third and on his way home
to score guerrielle with an rbi single
and it is four to nothing blue jays
pit's number seven coming to beau buchet
two on two out fourth inning 2-2
and a sharply hit ball into right field
for a base hit uriel's going to come
into scores simeon around a third rbi
single bow bashet and it is five to
nothing couple of singles are behind the
first 16 games in a row on base for
guerrero jr
[Music]
3-2 and he lines it into center another
base hit an rbi single for guerrero he's
three for three and it is six to nothing
and the orioles have loaded him up with
nobody out in the fifth
and first pitch swinging out to center
field springer is there and he's got it
will be a sacrifice fly for hayes who is
oh so close to a slam
in the air to right field down the line
tay oscar hernandez will make the catch
wins is tagging and coming home
and he is out at the plate
we will see if the orioles challenge
jansen had to come up the line a little
bit sure look like he got the glove on
his knee ryu loves it boba shed two for
three two singles a run scored and an
rbi the 1-1
and a bushette sends it well hit deep
left field gone
into the second row of seats number 16
on the season for beshette it is to one
seven eight nine against k
and pat valencia with the first pitch
swing off the glove uh biggio at third
so he didn't have to wait for long two
for three for pat second straight two
hit game and valaker's at third base as
mullins comes to bat and the 1-0
and a weak ground ball past the mound
biggio bear hands throws and they got
him and k might have gotten a piece of
that but it works out well for the blue
jason a good inning for anthony k 91
jays at the end of seven the ball and
two strikes now on t oscar two for four
on the night
now tay oscar sends one off the wall in
deep center espinal around third he'll
come in to score easily an rbi double
for hernandez it is ten to one
one one to mount castle
broken that flare out to center it is
down bay's hit
hazel score
and they'll stop mancini at third base
rbi single ryan mount castle orioles
with their second run ten to two blue
jays in the eighth
the two two on the way
and a ground ball to short backhanded by
bushette
bounces it over to biggio who makes the
pick cleanly and that'll end the
ballgame